Gill verd mais Monsieur le Maire moi
j'ai mis non tout de suite je ne vous
comprends pas parce que je savais très
bien où vous vouliez en venir en fait
derrière migrant il a étranger vous
voulez pas d'étranger chez vous voulez
gardz votre
ville fr
ber m amis va défiser tes
[Applaudissements]
anglaises moi j'aimerais qu'un jour tu
avoues quand même que sont tes amis on
s'en fout
am j'espère qu'un jour tuavouras com mes
amis ce serait mes amis mais ce ne sont
pas mes amis non monsieur le Maire très
franchement ça s'appelle la solidarité
nationale il y a des petits villages euh
aujourd'hui il y a la désertification
rural il y a des petits villages qui
sont sauvés par des migrants qui
arrivent par des gens qui viennent et
qui remontent des petits commerces
occupent des maisons qui étaient
désaffecté et vous voulez
pas vous avez refusé un centre d'accueil
pour migrant ça c'est vra che vous c'est
incompréhensible beaucoup critiqué il
faut
parte après non mais j'aimerais juste
après votre
V exactement sage juste regarde le
sondage Monsieur le Maire parce que pour
Gill Verdez merci 94,5 merci encore une
fois le génie des Carpates qu'est-ce que
tu dis à ça pourquoi tu es toujours à
côté de la plaque mais aujourd'hui parce
que c'est mais parce que c'est la
première impression c'est de dire non
d'accord mais arrête un peu arrête un
peu de évidment c'est facile
de au G R
s qu'est-ce que tu fais pour les migrant
toi mais qu'est-ce que tu fais pour les
migrant à part pas politique
jeoir citoyen non mais g il dit encore
n'importe quoi il fait preuve de
démagogie comme d'habitude non mais une
nouvelle fois merci gr la
France la
France mais la France c'est sympa le
plateau la France la France n'a pas
vocation accueillir toute la misère du
monde c'est pas la phrase d'un le c'est
la non mais c'est la phrase d'un ancien
Premier ministre socialist c'est la PHAs
d' anci pr
sociistiss parler ran qui est
intéressant s'il vous plaît parce que
merci mais je suis d'accord mais tu
dis mais cha toutes les interventions de
gî elles sont à côté de la plaque toi tu
habites à Paris tu habites en
île-defance tu connais pas la ruralité
tu connais pas la province tu connais
pas
la'oroité c'est
moiité c'est moi la ferme les vaches
c'est moi qui les é vous êtes malade ou
quoi insultez pas ma
familleul ma
[Applaudissements]
FAM plus
mtenant plus de tout il est toi tu
penses certainement que la France est né
en 1789 la France c'est 17 siècle
d'histoire peut pas on peut pas
accueillir des bateaux et des bateaux
évidemment évidemment
qu' tu dis encore n'importe quoi mais
c'est quoi ton argument alors
vas-yum mon argument si tu veux demain
demain toi et moi on va Porte de la
Chapelle et on va voir et ça ce sera un
argument factuel on va voir comment ça
se passe on va aller visiter les camp de
migrants celui qui s'était aménagé vers
l'Hôtel de Ville fairecouvrir la porte
de la ch est malade
[Applaudissements]
de la Chelle veux tu veux tu veux que
demain j'envoie les images j'ai fait un
documentaire non mais j'ai fait un en
face de l'hôtel de ville on s'est fait
casser notre caméra parce que les
migrants justement ne voulaient pas
qu'on les interrog les images mais
envoie Gilles verd ils vont bien
l'accueillir mais alors commentexlique
comment t'expliqu Gill alors le résultat
duondage laissz laissz c'est le moment g
verd les Français sont des gens
inhumains ind il est en train de dire
que les Français n'avent pas compris le
sondage pour ça regardé par la province
essay de comprendre et Monsieur le Maire
finalement suit la volonté de ses
administrés aussi c'est normal c'estd
que aujourd'hui les Français alors ça
peut être dur à entendre mais ne veulent
pas de grand à côté de chez eux on peut
on peut le retourner dans tous les sens
comme ça dans tous les pays européens
peur du déclassement le coût
social les problèmes
délinoup
dé s amis il a raison les autr
sont le public est un
con voulez prendre l'exemple de mayotot
il y a 500 personnesorig de Somalie il y
a un camp de 500 personnes à Mayot il
manifeste tous les jours pour les faire
dégager c'est indigne mais pourquoi faut
changer maot manre la manière dont les
Maoris sont trait
abentulent
pas Suren il conna Ren à rien mais
conna par trafic de drogue de
l'insécurité ils nen veulent pas alors
pourquoi veux-tu qu'on les met dans nos
campagnes il faut comprendre les gens
fait tu peux pas te substi-ce qu'on fait
des migrants dans 10 minutes on ré-
qu'on fait des migrants qu'est-ce qu'on
fait des
migrants arrête de parler sur les aut
déj m on les par pas on les par pas
comme on les parque pas comme des
animaux effectivement c'est ind ce qu'on
fait on les prend comme ça c'est les
migrants à la plage les migrant à la
montagne migrant à la campagne c'est
insupportable le plus intelligent le
plus celui qui plus le plus avoir un
élément de réponse ici c'est radan non
mais c'est des c'est des politiques de
coopération internationale qu'il faut
remettre en place migrant ça veut dire
quoi migrant c'est une personne qui
quitte son pays pour des raisons
politiques c'est pas qu pay pour des
raisons économiques demain c'est pour ça
d'où la nécessité de mettre en place des
politiques de c-éveloppement mais il y a
des il y a des livres qui sont écrits il
y a des solutions a lu un livre il a
écrit des livres on a vu les
commentaires tout à
l'heure j'en connais un j'en connais un
qui va venir souvent cy non mais
excusez-moi excusez-moi c'est votre
chouchou
[Applaudissements]
momentané
bonjour à il vous l' dit il fera comme
d'autres 10 émissions profitesen c'est
ton
moment il
vient je dis je pense qu'il sera là
après toi s sous vos
acclamations sous vos acclamations il
vient dénoncer un tissu de banalité
frroyable si si moi j'avais parlé de
coopération internationale vous m'z dit
ferme ta gueule connard tu es la France
de l'échec et lui il a le droit de
parler la
coopération
coopération coopétion
c'est mon André c'est mon André manouur
du
Breb j'adore j'adore ce gars je suis fan
pe dire ce qu' d'accord AC lui bien
voilà je te dis oui monsieur le Maire
oui je voudis répondre
à M
Pat
P je suis depuis 28 ans je suis maire de
droite d'une ville de
gauche 11000
habitants depuis vie politique j'ai été
aussi 15 ans député voilà j'ai dû
recevoir dans mon bureau 20 25000
personnes pr ça dans ta gueule non non
non non non non on est on n pas non mais
écoutez on n pas des ennemis on n pas
des adversaires on est des
contradicteurs moi si j'avais dit ça il
m'aurait dit ferme ta gueule le nouveau
oui mais mais j'ai le privilège de l'â
il laisser tranquille lui au moins il
est intelligent allez-y Monsieur le
Maire non mais il c'est pas la peine de
dire des choses comme ça 20 à 25000
personnes ça me fait du bien oui mais de
temps en temps faut arrêter de se faire
du
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bien il est très bon monsieur est très
bon Bernard les Français les Français je
les connais les Français de droite de
gauche extrême droite d'extrême gauche
je les ai tous connus tous ben oui je
tous connus forcément
forcément avec on est toujours bien élu
on fait 60 70 % des voix depuis
longtemps mais j'ai toujours en face de
moi des irréductibles dont vous seriez
par exemple si vous habitz àamix non
mais c'est normal c'est normal mais norm
les gens me disent tous la même chose
qu'il soit ancien élu socialiste de la
ville ou qu' soit droite libérale ou
conservatrice et C ils me disent tous la
même chose c'est-àdire on nen peut
[Musique]
plus non il il ad ils ils adorent cette
émission qu'on regarde en famille merci
Bernard merci
Bernard vous allez perdre des voix ne le
soutenez pas trop en direct mais non
mais calme-toi quand
même a pris la confiance j'ess j'essaie
d'être honnête je vous assure c'est pas
la grande bourgeoisie qui souffre de
l'immigration exactement grandoisi s'en
fout d'ailleurs qui qui a défendu
l'histoire des métiers en tension le
patronat avec la gauche ou l'extrême
gauche mais s'il y avait vraiment des
besoins pour les métiers en tension
comment ne les ne les a-t-on pas trouvé
alors qu'il y a chaque année 500000
étrangers qui viennent en France chaque
année 500000 est-ce que vous croyez
qu'il y a des besoins pour 500000
personnes dans les métiers entention
c'est une foutaise
his bien Bernard convaincu le discours
du patronat il est insupportable sur
cette question parce qu'il se fiche
totalement du sort des classes populaire
moi ça me déb je suis désolé de dire
comme ça vous avez l'air de quelqu'un
profondément humain pourquoi vous avez
accuseer les 50 migrants qui voulaient
venir chez vous dans un centre pour
demandeur d'asile mon alors erreur
erreur formelle votre honneur à vos
souet madame c'est à réellement que la
question s'est posée dans une petite
commune de 3500
habitants situé à une quinzaine une
vingtaine de kilomètres de de ma ville
et c'est vrai que je considérais qu'il
était invraisemblable qu'on ne consulte
pas le maire qu'on ne consulte pas la
population et qu'on décide de Paris
d'envoyer comme ça comme 50 paqu 50
migrants à votre bon cœur messieurs
dames en quelque sorte vous n'z pas cur
je disais c'est un ét jacobin c'est des
décisionob je crois que ce n'est pas ce
que pensent mes électeurs vousz pas
souhaité faire une consultation sur
votre dans ma ville je connais résultat
d'avance tu l'as eu tout à l'heure le
résultat de
fa-cl,9 baisse un pe quand même ça
baisse un peu 939 non vous inquiétez pas
g verd ne gagnera jamais un
sage ça n'arrivera jamais malheure
qu'est-ce qu'il veut lui moi pour
revenir sur le c'est pas ouf votre
intervention tout à l'heure non mais je
vous le dis vous êtes vous revenez de
Miami tout ça c'est bien sympa mais faut
bosser mon mais làtinent je te sens pas
je te sens pas qu'est-ce que tu veux
dire non je veux dire G a dit que c'est
facile de dire non on ne veut pas des
migrants moi je pense qu'au contraire
c'est facile de dire oui on veut bien
des migrants et souvent les personnes
qui disent oui on veut des migrants ne
sont pas concernés donc Gill si tu veux
des migrants et si tu veux les aider
accueille des migrants chez toi et fais
quelque chose et tu veux pas G
qui clur mais certainement l'argument de
Gill verd c'est dire
entire de mer
migire Migs
tu tu sa quo sa ce je vaire je vais
attendre par
langageor
biens tes amis de des conneries à faire
croire que tu dors dans une tente alors
que tu dors avec
Fatou taiu t'inquiète pas vasy alors
viens dire que tu dors dans les tes
alors tu es tranquillement chez moi
train de manger des GAL des rois connard
merci euh je vrais remercier Bernard
Caron qui a été excellent merci Bernard
merci
Bernard merci ah c'est
bon vous avez vu là on vient de voir
toute la malhonnêteté de Gil verdz mais
vraiment arrête on vient de voir toute
la malhonnêteté G qui dit il a eu un
langage corporel mais quelle
malhonnêteté je suis de droit de sortir
les images te jure je les ai moi les
images dit il a dit il a dit on fait
venir les bateaux on les accueille on
les remet dans le bateau et on leur
envoie non non j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit
on fait on fait venir les
accuse
vasyuse parce que moi c'est facile mais
le copain du patron accuse vas-y
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
accuse courageux ah oui tu foues là vasy
accuse
accuse le plus populaire
accuse allez retourne à B retourne
B pr décision pour pas polluer
vasy ou non on fait on fait on les
bateaux déjà j'ai pas envie qu'il
viennent mais si les bateaux viennent on
soig les gens on le donne à manger on
leset on les met même pas dans un bateau
les met dans un condition payor peux
dire qu'il jamais dit couler il jamais
dit